more than 90 years new yorkers have
packed into the city streets to watch
the thanksgiving day parade which means
that iconic tradition
has definitely stood the test of time
but now for the very first time it will
be a tv
only event all because of the pandemic
families are also scaling back their own
traditions as covid cases rise
and our jamie yuka shows us now how some
are getting creative and
finding safer ways to spend the holidays
together
two teaspoons of cinnamon the recipe for
thanksgiving 2020
is a helping of gratitude with a side of
careful attitudes
just like grandmas just ask inez tutti
adkins
the traditional thanksgiving dinner pass
the turkey pass the yams pass the mash
salt so each one of my family members
will get their own set of
serving utensils i even ordered some
plexiglass
you did i did i did so i'm
taking all of the precautions to be safe
adkins is moving the meal outside and
instead of her normal gathering of 75
it will be restricted to family members
sharing her compton california home when
you're in a family setting
you kind of get lacks on your mask so
i'll be sure to
always mass mass mass you know you're
the mask police
[Laughter]
last year atkins whipped up meals for
the city's first responders
on top of her loved ones but as a third
generation funeral director
she's seen the viruses impact health is
way more important than
being right next to one that you love
she says she's going to be the mask
police
yeah yeah yeah anytime i sneezed she
sprayed me with a light so i'm like man
is this my allergies like
relax but no one should relax this year
according to cbs news medical
contributor dr david agus
i will tell you i am scared i look at
hospitalization rates now and what the
current occupancy of icu beds are
and i see the holidays coming and i know
that not everybody is going to follow
those rules we really need to exercise
caution
music makes you lose control that's why
the rig family is putting a new spin on
their thanksgiving tradition
of a family dance-off so i have seven
siblings
so usually it's kind of a big big
gathering every time we get together we
choreograph something and we perform it
and
obviously this year we can't do a big
group dance
this year each family will create their
own dance which will be spliced together
and shared online
the kids it's like they just love seeing
oh whose video is better right so
they're like oh
redo our video the cousins did that that
was cool let's do ours again you know so
it's fun for them
the fun continued as a cousin's cookie
party also went virtual
this is me before thanksgiving dinner
and this is me
after this but despite recommendations
by the cdc to not travel for
thanksgiving
the rig family will join an estimated 50
million americans preparing to travel
with five kids the family is renting an
rv
and driving some 700 miles from plymouth
minnesota to
indiana they'll share the holiday with
becca's sister and father
and use the rv's kitchen bathroom and
bedrooms
so they can stay out of the house are
you guys doing any testing or is your
sister's family going to do any testing
before you all
come together yeah it would be
irresponsible for us to go down without
having
you know a little bit more awareness
around the risk that we're bringing to
our family especially with grandpa being
there
becca's dad just built this tree house
so the kids can play
outside but he's also diabetic and high
risk
that's why they've laid out clear rules
of etiquette dinner will be outside
and mass will be mandated
it sounds like you're you're trying to
take all the precautions and still have
a holiday
yeah we're doing the best we can there's
still something important around
creating a connection
with with our families we just need to
figure out a way to do it safely and if
we can be thankful for what we have
this year the hope is we'll end up
having more
next year for cbs this morning jamie
yukas los
angeles